quatorzième numéro de café politique
aujourd'hui au bistrot du théâtre à
montigny le bretonneux et je retrouve le
sens d'un gang bonjour je vous êtes la
responsable socialiste des yvelines vous
êtes conseiller régional d'ile-de-france
conseillère municipale aussi dans la
majorité
attrape vous venez d'être réélu mi juin
à la tête de cette fédération et daisy
blinn 63 24 % des militants et qui vous
soutiennent dans votre action comment
vous expliquez ce score qui valide un
petit peu votre action de ces quatre
dernières années le premier mandat a
débuté en 2012 deux ans et demi de
mandat et il ya plusieurs facteurs il y
avait je pense la reconnaissance du
travail
je suis quelqu'un qui en général on peut
ne pas être d'accord avec moi mais
comprenez que je fais plutôt une
bosseuse donc c'est un des éléments je
pense qu'ils expliquent aussi la
confiance
et puis après il y avait aussi un
positionnement de politique par rapport
au parti socialiste qui était là doivent
gauche de la gauche voilà qui était à
mon goût je rentre dans une logique de
soutien au programme de françois
hollande
du bourget voilà donc et donc il ya une
majorité de militants qui sont reconnus
dans les divines sur cette ligne comme
je portais aussi ce clip on était en
cohérence vous n'avez pas une certaine
malgré tout ressentez pas une certaine
frustration parce que vous le dites vous
êtes un soutien du françois hollande
avant le changement s'est avancé plus
maintenant il n'ya pas une certaine
frustration d'incarner une ligne
politique qui n'est pas majoritaire
aujourd'hui finalement si on s'en tient
au vote des différentes motions et puis
au congrès il ya mon nom parce que ce
soit la politique c'est un éternel
rapport de force donc c'est rien n'est
jamais fini puis c'est au sein de sa
famille politique pour voir les les
sujets les uns après les autres
il ya des sujets sur lesquels on arrive
à obtenir gain de cause il ya d'autres
où c'est plus difficile mais on et voilà
c'est pas oui pour répondre à votre
question même dans sa famille politique
un robinet
mais c'est vrai partout et on est on est
on est en permanence dans un équilibre à
trouver et
essayer de s'imposer par le débat par an
manière plus intelligente possible de
mes de s'imposer pour faire valoir ses
idées
vous êtes face à une femme à diriger une
fédération socialiste en ile de france
comment ça s'explique le parti
socialiste a du mal à se féminiser la
vie politique en général et pas facile
pour les femmes même s'il ya eu beaucoup
de faits et je prends manche pense que
si la gauche avait pas été au pouvoir on
n'en serait pas là puisque toutes les
voix de parité toutes les lois qui
permettait plus de représentativité des
femmes se sont à chaque fois des
gouvernements de gauche qui les ont
portés mais c'est un travail sur le long
terme
et puis c'est vrai que on essaye de
changer mais les réunions politiques
c'est le soir donc pour une vie
familiale c'est compliqué
comment vous êtes accueilli par vos
homologues hommes masculin jamais un
enjeu mais ressentie devant elles
prennent par le passé aujourd'hui
peut-être mais parler facilement
je n'ai jamais ressenti de de problème
de ce côté-là
après c'est plutôt parfois comment vous
avez réagi dans l'actualité récente au
niveau national à la démission de yacine
shawa on va préciser un petit peu ce
dossier c'était le nouveau faim éphémère
secrétaire national adjoint du ps en
charge de l'intégration qui a été
condamné par le passé pour des violences
conjugales qui a été nommé tollé sur
notamment les réseaux sociaux et la
démissionner ils ont joué leur rôle donc
vous avez tout à fait puisque l'on a
abandonné
au moins on peut critiquer les réseaux
sociaux mais ça joue ce rôle d' alerte
aussi il ya plusieurs choses il ya une
première faute politique qui était de
l'avoir nommé je pense que famille
politique on peut se tromper c'est pas
et puis ensuite il ya une deuxième faute
qui est la manière dont lui s'est
justifié pour pour démissionner je pense
que donner ce jamais ce dossier de ne
doit exister parce qu'il ne doit pas
être présent moi je suis pas pour qu'on
condamne les gens de 3 à 4 fois une fois
que les peines ont été
mais avant il ya aussi des postes à
responsabilités qui sont les postes
aussi on est exposé et je pense vous
pouvez trouver pleins pleins d'autres
personnes aussi capables que lui
d'assumer cette charge
c'était une erreur de proposer la façon
dont se déroule la politique aujourd'hui
le monde politique ont parlé de
l'intégration des femmes parler de ces
nominations qui sont des erreurs aussi
des faux pas au sein de votre propre
famille politique
ça correspond à l'idée que vous faisiez
de la politique oui parce que moi j'ai
jamais été une idéaliste je pense que
mon politique qui est l'équivalent du
monde dans lequel on vit donc on fait
des belles rencontres
parfois on dit que voilà ça valait
vraiment le coup parce qu'on a on a des
personnalités ou des camarades qu'on a
rencontrés qui deviennent des amis qui
viennent des proches
et puis il ya aussi des gens
bah oui ça c'était c'est un peu à quoi
je m'attendais c'est parfois difficile
parfois tendues mais c'est à l'image de
notre société qui a pas de raison que le
monde politique soit meilleur ou moins
bon il est il est le reflet de ce qu'on
vit aussi dans notre société
idéaliste pas carriériste non plus parce
que vous êtes le professeur d'histoire
géographie au civil vous continuez votre
activité d'ailleurs toujours des heures
d'enseignement et c'est donc cette
carrière en politique non ça va faire
carrière véritablement politique et
c'est pas c'est pas quelque chose de
qu'on programme savez moi j'ai eu la
chance pour le coup d'être plutôt dans
le fait d'être une femme en politique
m'a plutôt et des particules et ça m'a
peut-être permis d'accélérer certaines
certaines choses puis passe parce que
j'étais là au bon moment finalement j'ai
aussi pu accéder peut-être plus
facilement à certains postes
mais ça se programme pas prêt moi je ne
sais pas j'ai pas de problème à dire que
j'ai de l'ambition dire que j'ai envie
de faire des choses j'ai pas faire trop
de fleurs quand il ferme la figuration
mais c'est pas quelque chose que je
programme mais on prend les choses comme
ça vient dans la période sert plus
programmer une carrière politique à
gauche partout oui bien sûr on a confié
c'est évident vous auriez aimé être le
présidente de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
oui quelque chose c'était programmé
c'était programmé ça faisait partie des
options ça fait partie des choses qui
était possible en tout cas il y avait
une équipe qui était prête à prendre ses
responsabilités après
c'est une route de charge je sais que
michel laugier maintenant fait ça à
temps plein et pas beaucoup de temps
pour le reste donc c'est très lourd mais
quand on voit quand on a envie de
le s'engager en politique c'est aussi
pour abandonner trop m au delà du
courant national des difficultés de la
gauche
comment vous l'expliquez avec maintenant
beaucoup plus de recul cette défaite sur
l'agglomération
il ya eu pendant les élections beaucoup
de concentration sur la ville de magny
les hameaux par exemple où la gauche et
peur de perdre cette commune là et que
mathématiquement quatre communes à
droite comme à gauche ça fasse basculer
l'agglomération finalement sais pas ce
qui s'est produit c'est plutôt
l'opposition qui s'est effondré dans les
communes où la droite était déjà en
place vous avez fait des erreurs sur sur
lequel j'avais trop focalisation dit que
le point faible et emmanuel jamais je
sais que c'était quelque chose qui
revenait en permanence
moi j'étais assez sûr que bertrand au
lion qui fait un vrai travail de terrain
qu'un maire reconnu qu' qui ce qui passe
aussi un des heures des heures mais qui
est reconnu par ses concitoyens gta
c'est sûr qu'il serait réélu
effectivement le ce qui a changé c'est
nouveau là aussi un système nouveau
scrutin qui fait que les oppositions
sont représentés et que et qu'on n'a pas
réussi à être assez fort dans les villes
de droite comme montigny en gohelle en
cours ou là on pouvait attendre de
sièges en laye cas et ce qui nous a
fragilisés
cette opposition justement vous l'avait
incarné sur montigny le bretonneux
puisque vous avez siéger dans
l'opposition en matinée avant de partir
sur trappe
pourquoi vous êtes parti sur trappe
d'ailleurs en fait moi j'ai vécu saint
quentin je suis une enfant de saint
quentin en yvelines donc j'ai toujours
navigué entre montigné trappe
mes activités étaient beaucoup sur
trappe ma famille habitait juste limite
montigny trappe
voilà c'est pour moi les la frontière
communal a jamais été très beaucoup de
sens pour après j'étais élue
d'opposition a menti il s'offrit la
différence et l'opposition à montigny
guy malandain qui est venu
me demander quand j'étais conseiller
régional représentait la région sur les
lycées nord en particulier de trappes et
les venu me demander si ça
m'intéresserait de venir à travailler
avec lui et
forcément de la lande ans est une
personnalité politique à part qui peut
apprendre beaucoup aussi donc je me suis
testé une opportunité bientôt dans votre
tendance dans notre cour politico ça et
je me suis dit que c'était j'ai toujours
regretté justement de en politique deux
pas de pas pouvoir m'appuyer dans mon
expérience de jeunes élus sur quelqu'un
puisque j'aurais préféré pouvoir
justement travailler avec quelqu'un ou
au moins sur les premières années quand
j'étais confronté c'était très formateur
nicolas avoue dans les premiers les
premiers mandats
donc quand j'ai eu cette opportunité et
puis c'est vraiment pas pareil d'être
dans l'opposition et dans la majorité où
l'approché aussi on a dit que vous aviez
choisi la simplicité en partant à
trappes où c'était plus facile pour des
listes de gauche de s'imposer qu'à
montigny-le-bretonneux
sauf que j'avais fait enfin moi je veux
bien
entendre les critiques mais j'ai quand
même fait demanda donc sept ans et
six ans dans l'opposition je pense que
voilà j'ai appris ce qu'était le travail
d'opposition
c'était votre premier engagement
politique à montigny-le-bretonneux aussi
un conseil municipal était ce qui a
motivé cet engagement là parce que vous
l'avez dit ça a été difficile au début
il n'y avait pas d'appui vous n'étiez
pas au sein d'une majorité pour
apprendre justement il a fallu apprendre
tout seul un petit peu mais parce que
moi ont précédé parcours de vie moi j'ai
fait mes études j'ai commencé à
enseigner puis abandonnée c'était plus
suffisant il fallait que j'ai enfin
j'avais besoin de cet engagement
militant depuis très longtemps et puis
le constat aussi de certains moments je
viens d'une famille ancrée à gauche
syndicalistes
mais l'engagement politique c'est un
autre un autre pas et c'est aussi le
fruit aussi deux buts de constat de
conscience des injustices ou dès qu'ils
font car en dominant c'est pas possible
il faut s'engager et puis aussi constat
parfois de devoir le personnel politique
qui est en responsabilité on dit bah
finalement je donnerai pas de noms mais
aussi beau forcément plus mal quoi ce
soit à gauche ou ce soit à droite oui
c'est alors le camp ce qui est plutôt à
droite mais aujourd'hui par exemple mais
je pense qu'il sait ce qu'il faut dire
aussi à tous ceux qui hésitent à
s'engager sur que c'est pas un métier de
faire la politique c'est des convictions
et donc tout ça moi je n'appelle à tout
ce qui est qui parfois râle sont pas
contents à venir rencontrer s'engager en
politique et
à montrer qu'ils peuvent peut-être faire
mieux je n'ai pas de regret aujourd'hui
de vous être engagé en politique non non
non je pense que c'est difficile pour la
gauche aujourd'hui est que la gauche se
cherche encore l'engagement on peut pas
être conjoncturelles pas quelque chose
qui est qui et sur le fond après moi je
l'engagement c'est peut-être dans les
syndicats ça peut être associatif je
pense qu'à un moment donné il faut être
capable aussi de donner du temps pour la
société pour ce qui fait qu'on vit
ensemble mais les politiques
la politique peut encore changer les
choses oui moi je crois au delà des
associations parce que sur un terrain
associatif ya des gens qui s'engagent
aussi et qu'ils ont le sentiment d'être
plus utile que les politiques qu'ont
parfois trahissent aussi on ne change
pas on change pas la vie mais on peut
changer
on peut changer j'étais optimiste pour
la suite pour la fin de ce mandat en
tout cas sur le niveau national pour
pour la gauche sandrine anglade
conseiller régional ile-de-france
socialistes responsables du ps dans les
yvelines ont fait une courte pause et
ensuite on parle d quelques-uns
quelques-uns des dossiers qui vous
occupe actuellement
la suite du café politique avec la
responsable dans le département du parti
socialiste je vous propose d'écouter
pour débouter pour débuter par un micro
trottoir nous sommes allés à demander
dans la rue tout simplement ce que les
gens attendaient des socialistes dans le
département qu'elle puisse relancer la
politique culturelle qui est
complètement détruite en ce moment par
le nouveau président de la caisse qui
monsieur logis pour les yvelines il me
semble que le plus important c'est les
jeunes les jeunes tous les jeunes qui
sont 200 emplois c'est un scandale
national et ya toujours des difficultés
au niveau de l'emploi peut-être ce
serait bien de le travailler un peu là
dessus surtout par rapport aux jeunes
c'est quand même pas facile je trouve
n'aimerait à vendre un peu de sécurité
pour nos enfants
au niveau éducation scolarité et c'est
déjà un niveau national c'est le mauvais
donc si on pouvait au moins dans les
yvelines et dans la région améliorer les
choses ce sera pas plus mal
moi j'ai des petits-enfants et
franchement on l'aimé en école privée
parce qu'on n'a pas le choix
le transport aussi la structure
transport dont les retards on le subit
tous les jours c'était programmé par
exemple pour à saint-quentin de faire un
pôle multimodal donc des choses un peu
aboutis comme ça pour les transports par
exemple il ya beaucoup de choses les
transports on va y venir la culture
aussi forcément à saint quentin en
yvelines mais peut-être déjà de l'emploi
la formation des jeunes aussi c'est
quelque chose qui inquiète même au delà
de saint quentin en yvelines et du
département
la gauche a beaucoup déçu sur sa sur la
formation sur l'emploi il ya deux sujets
effectivement la jeunesse
l'éducation moi vraiment sur l'éducation
je pense que qui vaut du gouvernement il
ya des choses qui sont très bien qui
sont faites je sais qu'il ya beaucoup de
polémiques sur les rythmes scolaires sur
la crème du collège
ça fait partie des sujets où il fallait
bouger et où il fallait un peu bousculé
cette enseignante vous après cette
tuerie et jeu même si parfois que je
peux d'accord accepte ma collègue
je pense que le collège il faut faire
vraiment le collège unique
on l'a jamais fait jusqu'au bout ce
collège unique pour permettre d'avoir
une meilleure change pour l'ensemble des
enfants sur les rythmes scolaires c'est
pareil on a toutes les études montrent
qu on a une école qui fascinent les
enfants que on a des rythmes qui sont
pas tenables et on sait très bien que
on a eu ce débat là conseil municipal on
ne peut pas rajouter des heures et des
heures et des heures de maths de
français de maths de français à des
enfants qui emmenait son cadet quoi au
sens propre du terme
il faut d'autres inventer d'autres
choses et je pense que tout ce qui est
justement un sergent la question sur la
culture tout ce qui permet par la
musique par le théâtre par la danse de
sa proie y ait des savoirs ça permet à
en donner d'aussi qui est des déclics
pour des pour des gamins moi je crois en
vous beaucoup sur le périscolaire sur
sûr aussi les pratiques artistiques pour
aider les enfants donc ça pour moi c'est
un vrai projet de gauche les choix de la
nouvelle majorité de droite de centre
droit il faut faire des choix
budgétaires il ya des dotations en moins
le choix la coupe la coupe on va dire
s'est fait sur la partie des cultes de
la culture des associations il ya une
pétition vous avait relayé il ya une
forte opposition à ces différentes
décisions et après je pense qu'il y
aille a vraiment à faire prendre
conscience que c'est le mot vraiment le
mauvais domaine pour faire des économies
ça fait pas des économies structurelles
massive il ya quelques jours on était
ici au talent de saint quentin en
yvelines pour voir un spectacle qui
était monté par la paix m excuse avec
plus de 200 gamins
de saint quentin qui met avec la famille
qui pour la première fois selon mettez
les pieds dans un théâtre
là on est on fait de la politique
culturelle à vrai petit culturel avec
des enfants qui apprennent à s'écouter
qui apprennent une pratique artistique
qui qui sont aussi fiers de montrer ce
qui est ce qu'il faut mais ça c'est pas
possible s'il ya pu les subventions pour
l'association en question l'a fait mais
ce qu mais aussi pour la scène nationale
donc ça veut dire que il faut savoir ce
qu'on veut on peut pas d'un côté dire
c'est super bravo bravo aux bénévoles
et puis l'autre côté pas leur donner
les subventions entendre et voir le
choix de la nouvelle équipe c'est aussi
de dire que ce sont les municipalités
qui doivent aussi mettre la main à la
poche et des différentes associations
sauf que l'intérêt d'une
intercommunalité c'est justement la
mutualisation de penser pas une
compétence obligatoire c'est pas non
plus une compétence obligatoire pour les
communes ça fait partie de ces
compétences partagées
donc ça fait partie pour moi des sujets
transversaux qu'il faut que tout le
monde doit soutenir mais c'est vrai
aussi pour le sport vous dire tout ce
qui permet de de le vivre ensemble
une expression qui est galvaudé mais
c'est ça c'est bien on essaie on peut
pas non plus se dire chacun se replie
chez soi il ya plus lien il ya une
catastrophe la société auquel on va elle
fait peur c'est justement pour éviter ça
il faut créer du lien sur ces questions
budgétaires justement je propose
d'écouter un extrait d'une intervention
de michel laugier le président de la
casse qui s'était sur notre plateau il y
a quelques semaines j'essaie d'avoir une
vision très équitable sur l'ensemble des
chapitres demande mon budget au niveau
de la côte et agglomération de 50
sinon ce serait très facile il suffit
qu'on note brutaliser les impôts mais là
je pense que tout le monde tout le monde
serait pénalisé donc vous essayez des
associations si elles veulent continuer
à survivre même pour le plus bas niveaux
vont devoir augmenter les cotisations
par exemple pour leurs années en vue
d'amener accordé à chacun de s assumer
aussi parce que c'est pas si quand on
veut quelque chose on doit aussi
s'assumer et ne pas toujours attendre
des autres là aujourd'hui on revient à
nos compétences de base
c'est vrai que quand on a eu des
capacités financières plus importantes
il ya eu certaines largesses aujourd'hui
on n'a plus les moyens de ses largesses
il faut savoir revenir à la réalité et
jouer il suffit de voir aussi ce qui se
passe dans les autres collectivités
regardez en france il ya des
augmentations sur les taxes locales de
15 à 20% mais nous c'est parce que nous
voulons donc c'est parce que nous
voulons
par contre il faut être meilleurs
gestionnaires que
les équipes précédentes la gauche
mauvaise gestionnaire
il me semble qu'il était vice-président
transport et qu'il a participé aux
équipes précédentes mais
l'idée que qu'il faut une vision
équitable problème c'est que c'est pas
du tout ce qui ressort quand on regarde
les subventions regardez les subventions
sport par exemple ça pèse beaucoup plus
dans certaines communes que dans
d'autres on a eu des baisses drastiques
sur les subventions sportives pour
trappe
venant de la casse qui on n'a pas
l'équivalent sur l'emploi ou sur
montigny donc
ou alors on n'a pas la même vision de ce
qu'est l'équité mais quand on entend la
gauche qui gère mal globalement c'est un
argument qu'on entend souvent la gauche
dépense beaucoup dépenses mal on
commence à l'entendre de plus en plus
avec les élections régionales qui
approchent aussi c'est un argument
utilisé par la droite contre contre la
gauche vous y répondez dans les faits ça
correspond à rien puisque si on regarde
par exemple sur l'agglomération de saint
quentin c'est une agglomération qui est
financièrement se porte pas si mal que
ça qui est dans une logique de
désendettement si vous prenez la ville
de trappes
elle est depuis qu'elle est gérée par le
parti socialiste par guy malandain elle
s'est désendetté donc ça c'est des mots
mais dans la réalité ça correspond pas
grand chose
les élections régionales justement vous
êtes conseillère régionale sortante
on parle de voix en tête de liste dans
les yvelines ce sera le cas on n'en sait
rien encore pour tout vous dire je pense
que l'idée c'est d'avoir une sur
l'ensemble de l'île de france c'est ce
qu'a demandé claude bartolone parité des
têtes de liste nous on a
leader sur le département c'est à benoît
hamon donc moi je souhaite que ce soit
lui qui soit les analystes et ou en
numéro 2 pour faire des choix
actuellement il faut faire des choix ils
sont
on est en train de réfléchir à cette
élaboration justement sur cette source
et régional récemment sur notre plateau
toujours c'est eddie aït responsables du
parti radical gauche qui étaient invités
et nous l'avons interrogé sur les
conditions de l'union parce que lui
aussi il siège en tant que conseiller
dans la majorité actuelle avec jean paul
huchon
pour l'instant ce sont essentiellement
des affaires internes au parti
socialiste ce qui doit prévaloir
maintenant c'est le rassemblement de la
gauche parce qu'il nous faut conserver
cette région à gauche on a des raisons
de craindre si madame pécresse prenait
la présidence cette région donc je
dirais je n'ai pas d'appréciation
personnelle à apporter si ce n'est que
le bilan aujourd'hui de sept de ses 17
années de région à gauche sont aussi le
résultat de l'exercice politique d'un
homme fort qui était jean paul huchon et
d'un bilan d'une majorité de gauche
rassemblée autour de lui autour des
objectifs politiques que nous nous
étions fixés
donc c'est un méta son crédit maintenant
une séquence personnelle est présent sur
cette liste dès le premier tour moi j'ai
la volonté de repartir aux élections
régionales pour poursuivre le travail
engagé
maintenant les conditions du
rassemblement le parti socialiste si
nous devons nous allier à ce dernier il
doit aller créer il doit favoriser le
rassemblement nous nous attendons qu'une
fois claude bartolone a investi
officiellement à partir du 28 mai que
des contacts soient pris c'est à lui de
prendre contact avec ses partenaires de
gauche le rassemblement oui au service
des franciliens bien sûr et avec
l'ensemble des composantes et notamment
le parti radical de gauche
ça c'était fin mai sommes bientôt fin
juin
les conditions du rassemblement les
discussions ont lieu au lieu des
contacts sont pris les muscles si ça se
passe bien lieu oui avec avec le parti
radical de gauche
manière assez évidente le rassemblement
se fait à chaque fois je pense qu'il ya
la fois respect de ce que représente
cette composante de la gauche et en même
temps il n'y a pas non plus du côté de
du berger de vente pourrait nous poser
problème donc
le rationnement se fera avec eux sans
difficulté et je pense qu'avec les
autres formations possibles c'est plus
compliqué ce que disait il ya it est
tout à fait juste on a on a travaillé
avec les collègues du front de gauche
d'europe écologie les verts pendant
toute la mandature en s'enrichissant
mutuellement de
et parfois des débats mais c'est une une
majorité qui a bien fonctionné en tout
cas su avancer quel supporter des
projets et cc 1
c'est le modèle qu'il faut qu'on arrive
à reproduire qu'on n'arrive pas
forcément reproduire ailleurs mais je
pense que le mode de scrutin aussi aide
puisque là on est sur un scrutin glisse
alors que sur les départementales
par exemple on est sur un scrutin
binominal maintenant donc on
plus de difficultés à trouver des
équilibres politiques là on a les
équipes politiques qui permettent de
travailler ensemble
mais le parti socialiste joue gros sur
ce scrutin des régionales mais tant que
le parti sioniste et la gauche en
général et enfin quand on regarde on va
on va sortir bientôt le bilan d'un an
de nouvelles équipes qui ont pris des
responsabilités
l'équipe de droite dans les villes de la
région ile de france
quand on regarde la coupe qui on est et
qui ont été menées les domaines qui sont
concernés si on transpose à ce que ça
donnerait sur les régions ile-de-france
moi ça me fait peur on l'a dit sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin
concernant la culture et le milieu
associatif on est en train de casser
quelque chose qui met du temps à se
constituer et donc il ya des dynamiques
là qui pourrait être malmenés et donc
c'est pour ça que c'est pas la seule
alors je ne sais pas le parti socialiste
parce que là on est sur la question des
idées effectivement les idées de la
gauche sont ne sont pas les idées de la
droite et réciproquement mais au-delà de
ça politiquement pour le parti
socialiste ce serait politiquement
difficile aussi de s'en remettre
lundi six pales les départements ça
c'est la vie des partis politiques à des
guides des périodes de défaites des
périodes de deux victoires mais ce qui
est plus voir plus dur c'est il ya des
politiques pointé en engager qui portent
leurs fruits et abandonner les
changements ça peut être salutaire
parfois mais c'est aussi des coupures
qui sont des cas ce qui après
ont des impacts quand on les voit pas
tout de suite mais d'avoir des impacts
sur le plus long terme
pendant ces régionales on va forcément
beaucoup parlé des transports sort tout
sur l'île de france est obligatoire
on l'entendait dans le micro trottoir
d'ailleurs au début de cette séquence
pourquoi ça ne marche pas les transports
en ile de france vous connaissez le
dossier puisque vous en occuper pour la
région c'est ça quand on dit ça marche
pas il ya déjà des insatisfactions il ya
des problèmes
et aussi un trafic qui est absolument
dans le monde pas d'équivalent c'est et
on avait pris beaucoup de retard
il faut rappeler que la compétence
transports pour la région c'est
simplement 2006 qu'on récupère le stif
donc c'est à l'échelle de ce conte des
investissements qu'on doit faire c'est
c'est assez récent moi je me rappelle
les discours de valérie pécresse en
conseil régional où on était sûr le tout
voiture tout voiture tout voiture
donc maintenant on m'explique que c'est
plus tout à fait comme ça la même
logique
nous ça fait longtemps qu'on explique
qu'il faut mettre sur les transports
mais à l'aller les investissements c'est
ça se compte en millions et millions
d'euros par an milliards d'euros quand
on parle du grand paris on nous on avait
pendant toute la mandature vraiment mis
le paquet sur
la mobilisation sur l'amélioration de
transport existants c'est un débat avec
la droite qui nous expliquait que
c'était pas ça la priorité
on a tenu bon là dessus même si les
tenues secrètes le projet du grand paris
/ / / ce dossier là il faut continuer à
mettre peuvent être faites
on transporte pour améliorer pour
fluidifier tout ça rapidement au delà
afin même avant plutôt le grand paris
oui oui ça veut dire mais ça veut dire
mettre les moyens c'est c'est une
question de moyens c'est aussi parfois
des problèmes techniques on le voit sur
nous dans le département ce qui nous
pose problème c'est tout le noeud autour
de versailles qui est saturé donc là il
ya des problèmes techniques à lever mais
quand on a une volonté politique on
arrivera aussi bousculées ces problèmes
techniques
on arrive à la fin de cette émission une
dernière question 15 mai 2015 le
parisien nos confrères du parisien qui
vous consacre un article la gauche des
yvelines en plein chantier
c'est le titre vous êtes d'accord oui ma
bosse que l'aco notion de chantier me va
bien puisque c'est à dire qu'on
travaille pas avec des articles erronés
surtout sur les différentes défaites
non mais moi le des termes de chantier
je le prends au sens premier du terme et
il ya besoin de toutes façons de
permanence 2
sera confronté aussi la réalité de
réfléchir de bosser moi je crois
beaucoup au travail collectif
merci cendres une grande langue première
fédéral du parti socialiste dans le
département des yvelines c'est la fin de
ce café politique prochain numéro au
début juillet et ce sera un best-of
à bientôt